the FBI is out with the new warning
about an increase in fake kidnapping
calls
that's when criminals lie about taking a
loved one and then demand money well the
FBI is launching an awareness campaign
today to fight the growing scam an owner
is here with how the agency is asking
the public for health help and a good
morning I can't imagine getting a call
like this right good morning well we've
reported on the people around the
country who get calls from supposed
kidnappers telling them to send the
money or else now the FBI is
investigating at least one of the groups
doing it and wants to know who else may
have fallen victim to this scam I don't
think my adrenaline has ever been that
high the kidnapping calls came to a
father in the Dallas area he told me
that if I dropped this call that he was
going to kill my son and the Boston area
mother of this young woman and he said I
have your daughter she's in the back of
my van and I'm going to kill her
kidnappers called Valerie Sobel in Los
Angeles - saying they'd taken her
daughter the man says we have cut off
her finger and if you want the rest of
her in a body bag it's your choice to
get her back he told Sobel she'd have to
send them money and in the meantime if
you disconnect this phone she's dead if
you don't follow exactly what I tell you
she is dead she stayed on the line for
over two hours and sent close to four
thousand dollars to Mexico as directed
then the would-be kidnappers hung up but
her daughter hadn't been kidnapped she
was fine but the FBI says these fake
kidnapping calls are on the rise it's a
quick get-rich-quick scheme where they
can extort victims and have them said
wire money into Mexico Tim Ferguson is
an FBI assistant section chief who says
those calls usually come from criminals
in Mexican prisons and are you able to
track some of those phones back to these
prisoners in Mexico yes we have he says
prisoners use smuggled cell phones to
random dial numbers in the US and make
their threats then prisoners friends or
family pick up the cash sent by victims
to money transfer locations so why is it
focused or concentrated in the prisons I
don't necessarily think that is
in the prison system but I would say
that the large majority of the ones that
we do have or do come from the present
systems because the individuals there
don't have anything but time and they
have the resources to do so they've got
nothing but time to make lots of phone
calls that's correct
Ferguson says his agents are honing in
on one ring of criminals so far but the
FBI is now asking the public to help
find others by reporting any fake
kidnapping calls they've received the
FBI's goal to prosecute offenders
something that did happen in Sobel's
case at least one woman was indicted in
federal court on charges including
conspiracy to commit wire fraud they're
always learning and they're always
adapting and trying to figure out how to
make the extortion scheme better so how
do you know if the call you get is a
fake the FBI says out of state area
codes are one tip-off or longer foreign
phone numbers if there's an urgent
demand that you stay on the phone and
not get off the phone that is designed
to stop you from contacting your loved
one friends family or the police and the
request to wire smaller amounts of money
especially for example to Mexico from
multiple locations like Western Union
money Graham a place like that to report
a call you can go to the FBI's website
they want to hear from people even if
you didn't fall victim to the scam they
want you to call
what a predatory scheme I can't believe
it actually works so good that we're
making people aware of how not to fall
prey to it because people kind of
immediately panic and sometimes they'll
be a voice screaming in the background
they'll say that's your daughter
screaming for a life and I thank you for
that